each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it is my great pleasure to welcome Suraj
Chaudhary with an assistant professor at
Penn State University sasura graduated
in 2007 from upenn and he won the ACM
sigplan doctoral dissertation award so
Seurat has a wide variety of interests
he works in program verification
parallel programming logic in automata
theory and today he's going to talk as a
tell us about parallel programming so
what do you sir thank you so met it's a
great pleasure to be here so today I
will tell you about this parallel
programming language and programming
model that I've been working on for
almost a year now so the focus of this
model which is called chorus is data
parallelism so in the space of data
parallelism the main success stories
have been either when the granularity of
parallelism is highly code screen and an
example is map reduced or it has or when
we are working with dense data
structures with highly fine-grained
computations so an example of that is
these numeric computations that are
common in in scientific computing on
densities and in addition there are some
problem specific methods for example
people have worked a lot on paralyzing
n-body simulation and certain other
important problems like that so here our
goal is not to address just one or two
specific applications but a range of
data parallel computations over large
unstructured shared memory graphs and
here the granularity of parallelism is
not known in advance in fact it's not
predictable by static analysis so in the
average case there is a lot of data
parallelism in these problems but in the
worst case there is no parallelism at
all and as we will see there are lots
and lots of applications which fall into
this category and
our goal when we offer this model will
be a high level correctness as well as
efficiency so for example we would
aspire to achieve raise freedom at the
language level or deadlock freedom and
also we would like to express the
essence of this kind of parallelism so
that our compiler and runtime system can
take advantage of that now a classic
example of an application of this sort
is delaunay mesh refinement so here the
problem instance is a triangulation of a
set of points so you are given a set of
points and you are building triangles
with these points as nodes now what you
want to achieve are these two properties
so the first property is known as the
deal on a property which is that no
point is contained within the
circumcircle of a triangle as you see
that's the case here ok but the second
property is what's known as the quality
property which is that all the triangles
that you get in this mesh they satisfy a
certain goodness constraint which is
that in this case there is no triangle
where there is an angle with that's
greater than 120 degrees so typically
you get meshes when this quality
constraint may not be satisfied so what
you want to do is that you want to
refine the mesh you want to add new
points to it andhra triangulate it so
that there are no bad triangles left in
the mesh so this is the problem of dill
on a mesh refinement now let's look at
this a little bit more closely so the 1
classic algorithm for this problem works
as follows that you collect in a data
structure known as the cavity all
triangles whose circumcircle contains
the new point so you have added a new
point to define the mesh and now what
you do is that you collect all these
triangles and as you have seen here in
the second picture I have colored them
in a different color and then you retry
angulate them like I've done in the
picture on the right so actually it so
happens that even after you do this
thing the some new triangles may again
violate this quality constraints so you
have to continue but there is a
guarantee that this algorithm will
terminate so that's a that requires some
reasoning so let's look at this
algorithm in the form of pseudocode so i
have a mesh and then i have a work list
in which i am going to collect all these
bad triangles and then i'm going to pick
a triangle from this work list i'm going
to create a cavity i'm going to expand
the cavity and then i'm going to retry
angulated and finally i am going to
update the mesh and i am going to
continue until there is nothing left in
the work list so observation number one
there is no kind of so these cavities
that we have here these are contiguous
regions in the mesh but the second
observation which is not actually
obvious is that in the worst case the
cavities can encompass the whole mesh so
you can create such an instance now what
do we do if we want to paralyze this
algorithm so the first observation is
that here we are working on a complex
unstructured graph which is a mesh and
we do not really have properties
necessarily that we can use in
parallelism for example the size of a
cavity as we have noted can encompass
the entire mesh so what we will do here
is that we are going to view this
problem more abstractly as a computation
over a graph and in this case we can
view these nodes in this graph as
triangles and edges representing
adjacency between triangles and so by
the definition a cavity corresponds to a
neighborhood a contiguous region in this
graph and we are going to use this
observation later but let's let's
continue so now what's the atomicity
property that we want to satisfy we want
these cavities to be read triangulated
atomically and non overlapping cavities
may be processed in parallel however
this
question of what can be done in parallel
seems impossible to handle with static
analysis and the reason is that the
shape of the data structure it changes
greatly over time moreover it's
extremely input dependent it's easy to
create a pathological instance where you
are going to get no parallelism at all
and there has been a lot of work on this
type of parallelism of late notably by
kesha fingerless group at UT Austin so
just to note that this is not just one
isolated application there are lots and
lots of similar problems so in the space
of meshing there is mesh refinement
there is triangulation there are
problems in clustering ray tracing
maintenance of social networks graph
blob problems such as spanning tree and
flow computation n-body simulation
sparse problems in scientific computing
sparse matrix vector multiplication and
even some program analysis problems so I
added this for the effect because I
primarily work on program analysis
iterative dataflow analysis and
patronage simulation so so this then
represents a class of applications which
is fairly large but where these
traditional static techniques of
extracting parallelism don't really work
so what can we do about it so what I'm
going to do here is that first I'm going
to present more abstractly our
programming model and show how it can be
used to encode that application I showed
de Lana mesh refinement and then I'm
going to present a more concrete
language called J chorus which is an
embedding of the model on top of the
sequential subset of Java and then I'm
going to talk about implementation and
finally I'm going to talk about some
ongoing work on embedding this model
into the into habanero Java which is an
offshoot of ibm's extent language yes
this at least kind of applications right
now how many does silk I work Steve
patience how they perform so as you'll
see our implementation has some stuff
related to work styling cues so we are
using some of the ideas there but but I
do not think judge that alone will
suffice so we are going to come to that
and maybe at the end we can discuss this
in more detail so one of the interesting
observations here is that in in all
these applications there is a common
property of locality which is that even
though you are doing computations that
in the worst case can require global
access to a gigantic data structure in
the typical scenario that is not at all
so so for example we ran some
experiments on a mesh of about 100,000
triangles from these benchmarks from
from cache of tingly and we found that
the average size of a cavity is actually
only 3.75 triangles and the maximum
cavity size was 12 triangles so in that
case there is a lot of parallelism in
this problem and the essence of that is
perhaps this average case locality but
again there is no way to know this ahead
of time what is the extent of locality
in a particular in in a for a particular
application so the main idea of chorus
is that since we are working on these
local regions in the data structure why
not let these regions be the drivers of
the parallel computation just as objects
are the drivers of computation in in
object-oriented programming or
concurrent objects are the drivers of
computation in in the actor model so we
are going to make this more clear soon
so let us first phrase the problem a
little bit more abstractly so I'm going
to view from now on these problems as a
problem of parallel computations on
graphs so here I have a giant graph and
this represents the heap and the object
CR correspond to the nodes the edges
here correspond to the pointers and I am
going to refer to an induced sub graph
in this in this heap as a region and so
an assembly in our terminology is a
region in this heap that is equipped
with a
of control so the typical situation
would be that these Assemblies would be
short-lived and speculative and we are
going to see what this means in in the
context of some applications so one
point I would like to make here is that
this might remind some of you of the
actor model of computation so as we will
see later there are some important
differences but for one here we have
this property that all these regions
that are there in the various assemblies
in the in the heap at one time they all
form partitions of the heap and they are
all isolated objects in them are
completely isolated okay and second is
that there is no a priority guarantee on
how big a region might be it might
consist of one object it might consist
of the entire team okay so in a
situation like ours we need to talk
about not just static data partitions
but partitions that actually change over
time because of the very dynamic
adaptive nature of these applications so
our primitive for synchronization in
fact the this is the only primitive for
synchronization here is merging of
assemblies so here we have assembly I
and assembly J and there is an edge from
this I to J and so i can now merge with
jay and the result is this bigger
assembly that we see at the bottom and
this assembly j which previously had
ownership of that region that now ties
so in order to rule out races we require
that j must be in a so-called ready
state that is it should not be doing in
the middle of doing some sort of an
imperative update well this merge
happens so again I will clarify what
that means so then merging is a way in
which we a course on the granularity of
parallelism in the heap so how do we
define the granularity of parallelism
well it's splitting so here what we have
is that we have assembly I and I has now
split into these assemblies I one
through I six okay and then this tau
okay so let me actually get get to that
in a little bit so
for now let's just get this picture that
assembly I have split into these
constituent assemblies now one of the
things to note here is that this J is
completely oblivious to what has gone on
inside I here so I can split Jay doesn't
have to know in other words this
splitting operation is not actually a
synchronization construct where as in
the previous case for merging there is
actually synchronization involved
because we are saying that you know Jay
must be in a ready state while the merge
happens okay finally and assembly being
a having an imperative computation
associated with it can actually modify
it seep as well as its local variables
so the restriction though is that
objects inside and assembly are isolated
which means that you are not allowed to
you know follow that pointer read some
data and do some modification of that
that's not permitted everything else is
permitted so okay that sounds nice but
what do programs here look like so what
we do here is that we just generalize we
just seek inspiration from
object-oriented programming and we
define the notion of an assembly class
and an assembly class consists of a set
of local variables a set of guarded
updates so it's a the computations here
are in the guarded command style and
there is a constructor which creates an
instance of an assembly from an assembly
class and then there are some things
called public variables which I am going
to explain soon and a program is simply
a set of classes and each assembly we
are going to view it as this sort of a
very simple state machine so each
assembly can be in a busy state which
means that it's now executing an update
so remember that we have these guarded
updates so the pattern is that evaluate
the guard execute the update then come
back and then again do this again and
again right so this is the state when an
assembly is executing an update and this
ready state which is where the assembly
starts and this is the default state and
it goes back to that after finishing an
update is is a state where and assembly
can actually be preempted by another
assembly so an assembly can now be
merged by a neighboring assembly and
died as a result and when an assembly
it just goes to this terminated state so
let us now look at the structure of
computations here a little bit more
closely so first of all these guarded
updates are simply of this form that
there is a guard and there is an update
and the rule is that this guard is
executed atomically after that this
update is only going to refer to the
objects that are owned by the assembly
therefore there is no further need for
trying to acquire locks over individual
objects so that's the idea so again
guard is executed atomically update only
refers to the objects that are owned by
the assembly so now the construct for
marge is going to happen actually within
guards so this is a slight difference
from from standard guarded command
languages that our guards can actually
have these effects of merging two
assemblies however they cannot modify
the heap so they cannot have effects
that are imperative in that sense they
cannot touch the heap however they can
change the structure of concurrency in
the heap so here at the top I have this
guarded command module followed by s so
this says that you know try to do this
March so I when it executes it tries to
do this march along u dot F so you is
that object at the top u dot F therefore
is the reference which points outside of
I and it says that try to merge with
this if this much goes through you know
in that case the guard evaluates to true
and in that case execute the command s
on the new region that you acquire as a
result yes you are you and F are those
should I think with osas two arguments
the merge that is capacitive both of you
and the unit no you should see it as u
dot f as in Java that it's a reference
so you is you is a package
how do you know what you're urging to
book what's the capital s so s is the
statement that you are going to execute
after you do that see if you you're
saying that the parameter to merge is
look there's just one parameter right
and it's going to be the whatever the
acupoint student yes how do you know
what you're going to join that too so
you have no control over that aside from
one thing that's so that I have not
shown here you can specify the type of
the assembly that you are going to join
with but aside from that there is no
control about who you will merge with so
any particularly find not merge with
will they be assembly that the energy
you know you is what you contain so you
will within i right I is trying to
execute this so u dot f is the reference
that points out sci fi the whole is
simply yeah so sorry I it may look like
that's just that one object no it's a
whole assembly and then there is a
slight refinement of that which is that
you know you can also guard this with an
additional guard which is G in this case
we just says that G is a constraint
that's evaluated on this assembly I
again and when this property G is true
at that point you try to execute this
March if it goes through then you
execute s
and as for guards that's really what we
have so we do not really need anything
further and the split so far as for
splits so what we have is that it's just
a command that's executed within that s
thing that I showed that there is a
guard and there is an update and that
update was that s that that symbol s so
this split is executed within that and
when a split happens it just produces
something like this and the syntax is
like this that you can do split tau
where tau is a class is the class of the
assemblies that are being produced as a
result of the split and this p1 through
PN is going to be the parameters that
you pass to the Constructors of this
these new assemblies and that's the way
you pass some local state from this
parent assembly to these children
assembly yes simulation can say split
cannot fail because it doesn't depend on
anybody else right it's a completely
local operation whereas marginal
synchronization construct and as a
result that might potentially fail
and finally local updates are as i said
before so this is just like in java
except again if you try to access
something that's outside your assembly
then you are going to get an exception
and there are some refinements of that
so a one version of Marge for example is
that you can create a new assembly of a
new type when you perform the March
because remember that previously when I
merge with J it was just I so now you
can also create a new thing in the
process and likewise you can there is
also a refinement of split which is that
earlier we had to split into all these
individual components assemblies that
contained only one object each however
you can also you know basically release
one of the objects in the in the
assembly and and create one assembly out
of that and that would be to split one
ok but the most interesting constructs
are really the ones I showed earlier
okay so enough about this sort of
abstract discussion of the language
let's look at an application so here
let's say we try to try to implement
this dellanna mesh refinement
application in this language so how will
we do this so we will choose two kinds
of assembly classes one will be these
triangles and another will be these
cavities and what does each triangle do
each triangle determines if it's bad or
not if it is bad then it merges with a
neighboring triangle to form a cavity ok
what about a cavity so a cavity can
determine whether it has all the
triangles needed to finish the retry
angulation right and that's a local
operation so if it finds that it needs
more then it tries to merge with a
neighbor if it finds that it has enough
then it's going to just retry angle it
locally and then split back into these
triangles because now you sort of back
into the default state all these
triangles are back and you are going to
continue this process is going to
continue until there is no further
activity in this solution if you will
solution of triangles which are just
merging and splitting with each other so
the code then looks kind of like this
that
I have one assembly class called
triangle and the action within is that
March with v dot F so let's say V dot F
corresponds to our neighbor so you merge
with that and become a cavity when this
property is bad is true meaning that you
are back this triangle is that okay and
that's that's the only thing that a
triangle does otherwise it just stays in
active what about a cavity the cavity
determines if it's not complete if it's
not complete then it's going to march
with again let's say this points to an
arbitrary neighbor and it's going to
form a bigger cavity and if it's
complete then it's going to retry angle
it and then it's going to split into
these individual triangles that form it
so what happens then if there is a
conflict suppose you are trying to grow
a cavity you are trying to merge with
more and more triangles and in parallel
there is another cavity that's being
formed and these two things collide what
happens then so remember what we said
that when one cavity when one assembly
Marge's with another the assembly that
is on the receiving end of the marge
dies as a result so what that means here
is that there is one cavity that's being
formed another cavity that's being
formed and then one cavity gets absorbed
by another so what this will lead to is
that all the work that one of the cavity
is dead up to this point will have to go
right in essence the computation that
you are trying to achieve is rolled back
however so there are so there are some
subtleties here so in some sense the the
work that you set out to do that will
not be finished you are kind of back at
the original state however at the end of
this all this when the cavity that that
is the killer if you will the cavity
that does the absorption this cavity at
some point will have done its job and
then it's going to split again and then
the original thing can start all over
again from scratch okay are there
questions yes every time we mention are
encouraging
the homework in other cases we need to
mattress to cavity so I'm going to
address the the lifelog deadlock issue
soon but the you can know you cannot
hear you cannot merge with two cavities
at one time you are going to merge with
one assembly who's going to be your
neighbor and but when you do the March
then the cavity that's on the receiving
end of it that has to go and as a result
all the work that he has done Alta at
this point that work is basically
rendered worthless right because you are
not using your not able to finish what
it started however the point is that
eventually this cavity who killed it
killed this other cavity this cavity
will have finished its work and then
it's going to split off again and then
presumably if that what still needs to
be done that work will again start from
the beginning and you it's going to you
know reach its final point if it's not
interrupted by anybody else and then
it's going to do the rip triangulation
and then split back and then it will all
be over so let's now look at some of the
other approaches so I'm going to give a
few other applications that we can
encode in this style but let's look at
some other competing approaches so the
first question is of course what about
threads and explicit locking so here the
perhaps the main objection is that the
heap in shared memory languages is a
completely global entity and furthermore
you have arbitrary aliasing and as a
result when if you are trying to ensure
that there is no no there are not
multiple objects that are trying to
multiple multiple cavities that are
trying to work on the same object at the
same time that's that's very hard to do
and it's also low level and error-prone
so what about software transactions so
here what happens is that this burden of
reasoning is really passed on to the
transaction managers and in most
implementations of software transactions
the conflicts between two activities
that are happening in parallel but
happen to conflict on some data item
that's detected by monitoring reads and
writes to the memory and as well as
this either leads to you doing some sort
of conservative analysis and and getting
conservative results or it is very
expensive because dynamically you have
to really search the entire memory and
try to try to see if there is a conflict
or not so what about static data
partitioning is there for example in
languages like extent so here the
problem is the unpredictable nature of
the computation you might have started
with a data partition that was very nice
but after a while because of all these
changes it may become quickly bad so you
need some sort of an adaptive mechanism
and really what our constructs for
margin split offer is a is a way to
implement this adaptive nature of
isolation in using a few simple
constructs so finally what about actors
so the actor model is perhaps the most
well-known and the oldest type of data
oriented parallel programming so if you
are going to model this problem of mesh
refinement using actors what you do is
that you would give each actor a set of
cavities right and then what would
expansion mean it would mean that one
actor passes around some triangles to
another actor so now there are two ways
of doing this one is that you would copy
the triangles and send it to the other
person but this presumably would be too
expensive but then the other option is
to just pass around references but on
the other hand this introduces problems
like aliasing and races note on the
other hand that in our model the there
is no aliasing of objects so as a result
of Marge's and splits objects get
transferred from one entity to another
an entity does not have aliases to
objects that are owned by other entities
so that's an important point so finally
if I'm talking about irregular
applications I have to talk about golova
which is cache of Bengali system for
irregular data parallel applications so
this is in this system what they do is
that they annotate data structures with
information about commutativity
associativity etcetera and have
iterators that are not just over lists
but all
over sets and posts and this is a very
different style of programming hours we
see hours as an alternative that's
trying to address the same problem okay
so let's now look at a few other
applications so another application that
has been looked at a lot in the setting
of this sort of parallelism is barocas
algorithm for minimum spanning tree so
the parallel version of this is as
follows that you have this graph and in
the beginning you start with all these
small spanning trees which correspond to
just one not a few nodes each and then
these small spanning trees merge to form
bigger and bigger spanning trees until
finally you're going to get this
spanning tree that that covers the
entire graph so this is pretty obvious
how to model this in our language so
what you do is simply you model these
spanning trees as Assemblies and merging
is just a direct construct in this in
this system another application from
pinger Lee's benchmarks is that are
focused communities so the goal here is
that you have a giant social network
where there are updates being made
continuously and what you want to do is
that you want to maintain communities in
this network where a community is
defined as a sub graph which is such
that the measure of closeness with in
the graph is bigger than the measure of
closeness between any node in the sub
graph and something outside so basically
you're in a community if you are more
tightly connected to people within the
community rather than people outside the
community so of course this graph is
being updated constantly and as a result
the the structure of these communities
change all the time and now a sequential
algorithm for this is as follows that
you suppose you want to determine the
community of one person so you do this
sort of a greedy fixed point computation
that you keep on adding nodes if you
find that this edition of this node
increases some objective function and
you otherwise you know you
to shed some notes so again it's pretty
obvious how to do this in our setting
you use an assembly to represent such a
community and then the shedding and
growing of communities the shrinking and
growing of communities is captured using
the Marge and the split primitives so
okay so a few notes so first of all note
that in the worst case there is no
parallelism here at all the entire heap
merges into one neighborhood second note
that the merges and the splits here are
unordered so for example there is no
real ordering between a marg that
happens between said this and some
assembly here and the split of that
assembly so it's all completely true
concurrency semantics so what about data
races well so there are no data races
because each assembly only updates only
modifies locally isolated objects and
Marge's happen only when and assembly is
that the recipient of the march is not
within the in the middle of an update so
of course the definition of a data race
is that you know multiple imperative
computations do not attack the same
object at the same time whether for
reads or writes so what about deadlox so
imagine a situation like this where
there are two assemblies and this
assembly is trying to merge with this
assembly and this assembly is trying to
merge with this assembly so in other
words I is waiting for J&J is waiting
for I so this is perhaps the closest to
what we can define as deadlock in a in a
situation like this but note that
Marge's here are unordered so for
example if you have a situation like
this then the runtime system can really
execute one of the two merges and when
that happens the other merge the other
assembly is dead there is no further
requesting and therefore there is no
further waiting progress happens because
a bigger assembly is formed and that
goes on to do whatever it needs to do so
the key to this is this pre-emptive
nature
of assembly is that when an assembly is
in the ready state then it can be killed
by anybody there is no protection
whatsoever and furthermore at the end of
every update you have to come back to
this top-level ready state so assuming
that update stormy night you are going
to be able to resolve such a situation
eventually yes so when gene wants to
rush right so it says to the system I
want to merge with that silly
owns Jade our end the object are
absolutely us and so if in the process
if I is critical so it would actually a
depth much of it summarizes some some
child of mine absolutely absolutely Jake
not mean I absolutely yeah say that
that's key to this there a speedo and
delicate me yes so of course I said all
this but this assumes the existence of
some kind of omniscient runtime system
which is going to just look at all of
these things all of these requests and
just order them and resolve them in
somehow but if you are going to write an
implementation for this system in a
honest a multi courses multi-core
machine then there's not going to be
just one scheduler that is centralized
somewhere so we'll have to talk about a
more distributed runtime system and I'm
going to talk about that in a little bit
so then we will have to reason about
deadlock at a slightly lower level and
we will do so okay but before I go there
let me just present the language for
which that runtime system is built so
this language is known as J chorus this
is simply chorus on top of sequential
Java so in fact these obstructions of
assembly classes can very naturally be
integrated with an object-oriented
language because we already have notions
of object classes so what we do is that
on in addition to that we also now have
these classes of assemblies and we have
these method calls from within the
assembly class bodies so we saw those
guarded comments right so inside the
updates we can now make method calls and
these calls can now be on any of the
object classes that I've defined in the
sequential part of the program and there
are a few extra features that I did not
show in the previous core version of the
model so we have now objects which are
read-only and mutable and these are
specified as part of the types and for
example a read-only data item can be
shared ubiquitously bye-bye assembly is
all over the system and
mutable objects are like what what I
explained earlier okay so in that case
the code for mesh refinement would look
something like this I'm not going to
give you the details but let's just look
at this this little piece here so I have
the declaration of the cavity assembly
and inside that I have this declaration
of actions and inside actions I have
calls to these methods which are just
Java methods and similarly we have these
other assemblies and and in fact we
found that when we looked at this mesh
refinement algorithm miss refinement
application and try to write it in
chorus we found that most of the code
was actually just sequential Java code
we only needed to add about 15 lines of
code which were which corresponded to
chorus so we really could just take the
sequential version of the program and
then add these 15 lines of code on top
of that and we got a chorus version of
the program which I thought was quite
nice so this is the language aspect of
the problem so what about the systems
aspect of the problem so that's what I'm
going to discuss now so one thing to one
problem that you hit as soon as you try
to implement something like this is that
the parallelism that you express in the
language is potentially huge so in any
realistic system which perhaps as eight
cores or 16 course what you need to do
is that you would have to have some
mechanism for mapping these hundreds of
thousands of possible assemblies to the
course in the system so how to manage
this this mapping is a funny question
and the questions that are that arise
here are what are the right mapping
strategies what are the right scheduling
strategies because a core now contains
maybe tens of thousands of these
assemblies and you have to execute all
of them in some order so that raises the
question how do we schedule things how
do we balance loads right so this this
graph that we have here that's a
completely unstructured things so it's
conceivable that after a while some of
the course will be doing all the work so
we need some sort of
balancing strategy and finally what are
the right data structures for
maintaining the relationship say between
the objects and their assemblies how do
we determine which assembly an object
belongs to so all of these questions
need to be addressed and this also needs
to be hidden from the programmer and
shoved into the body of the runtime
system so designing this runtime system
is quite a challenging task so the mean
lower level abstraction that we have is
known as a division so a division is a
set of assemblies that's map to a core
ok so here I see these two divisions so
this division contains these assemblies
and and likewise so now note that some
of the magis are now actually local
within divisions because a division now
contains many assemblies right so if one
assembly within a division wants to
merge with an assembly within the same
division that's just like a local
operation it's not really parallelism
however there are D is a remote modulus
which is that what if this assembly
wants to merge with this assembly so in
that case there needs to be an actual
request sent from one division to
another and that would require some real
synchronization so so these are the so
this is the high level structure of the
problem and now what we perhaps want to
do is is that we want to minimize the
amount of synchronization that happens
across divisions we want to make most of
these modules local so how do we do that
ok so the main strategies here are that
first the divisions are adaptive which
is a which is our heuristic for reducing
the number of remote modules so the idea
here is as follows that when say this
assembly tries to merge with this
assembly you are going to migrate this
assembly to this division right and
along with that you are also going to
migrate some of the nearby assemblies to
that division so the result of that is
that since there is this locality
property in these applications that
typically if you want to merge with and
assembly you're perhaps going
March want to merge with some nearby
assemblies if at all right so that's why
this heuristic of migrating some chunk
of some local collection of assemblies
from one division to another that
actually turns out to help quite a bit
so the second thing is the heuristic for
load balancing which is done just by a
simple modification of this of this
migration strategy which is basically
when you are doing the migration you can
also do some some computation and make
sure that you know the migration is
happening from the direction of the core
which has more assemblies to the
division to the to the to a division
which as pure assemblies so that way you
are just making sure that assemblies are
always migrated from the core with more
more assemblies to the one with pure
assemblies yes case when you have an
assembly as well so that could require a
series of Marge's right so that would in
that case there is at one point where
it's merging from a priceless smaller
than right so sooner all these are just
heuristics so you cannot just apply them
completely blindly so you have to also
put in other heuristics so in all these
applications that we considered it's not
really that well with the exception of
that spanning tree algorithm it's not it
doesn't really happen that you need to
merge with everything to form a form a
big heap so if it turns out that you are
you are going to you're forming bigger
and bigger assemblies and you are just
one division is going to have lots of
stuff and this cannot be avoided then
well what can you do you just have to
deal with that
and the third heuristic used to use the
union-find data structure and the reason
for this is that these Assemblies here
are disjoint sets right so in order to
maintain the relationship between
objects and what assembly it belongs to
we can use a Union find data structure
so basically when there is a marg what
we do is that we use the Union part of
Union find and when we want to find out
what assembly an object belongs to we
use the find part of that and so this
also seems to seems to give quite a bit
of benefit and finally we have this
token passing strategy to prevent
deadlox in in this system so as I
mentioned earlier that there is no
runtime system that's completely
centralized right that's going to just
resolve all these different mod requests
that are being made simultaneously so
what we do is that we have this token
passing strategy which is used in many
other distributed programs as well to
handle the remote Marge's so if you are
going to do the local merges these you
can do at any time at your will but as
for the remote merges they are going to
you're going to need access to this
global token to do that and therefore
that introduces serialization and and
that prevents deadlox so there is a
little bit more subtle tea to the
deadlock freedom argument but I want I
think I will avoid that I can answer
that if there are questions on mobile
talking anymore
right so this right so what happens is
that you batch all the remote requests
so for example you know you have a you
have an S you have a division right
which is executing all its assembly is
in following some scheduling policy so
now you see that there is a remote March
that's being requested in some assembly
so what you do is that you batch all
these requests to into a queue and then
when the token comes to you then you try
to execute all of these things at one
time and this means yes that at one time
only one person can do these sorts of
remote modules but since you are
batching it and since there are so many
assembly is typically parkour it seems
to work out reasonably actually an
efficient event masterwork a kind of
global so what kinda masterwork a
singular single schedule I don't know
what that having single scale run but
you need to distribute that right how
how are you going to happen is not
distribute sure sure but you have if you
have these multiple cores so where will
this master scheduler run and how are
you going to find out it's like they
love you home thinking and maybe do the
load balancing much more efficient
sure but whether was after scheduler run
but then that means that in order to do
the scheduling you are going to have to
communicate right from that code to the
core which possesses the assemblies so
you will need to basically communicate
for every assembly that's going to be
executed and that will require a lot of
synchronization spoken yet if we have
two assemblies they're trying to merge
to the same point they matched up these
are remote mergers next up I want to go
with I he wants to go die who gets how
do you prevent like a deadly embrace
time right so the reason is that when
the token comes to one of the divisions
it's going to try to execute this thing
right this much so once that marge is
executed then that other request is
voided because that assembly is dead
it's just not there any longer yeah just
yeah it's just dead so this is the
structure of the system so you take a
program and then you pass it through the
compiler front end and then you create a
java translation and then finally we
have this runtime system which is a
layer over the Java Virtual Machine so
the code for this is available just send
me an email so this web page should be
up in a few days it's not yet up now but
if you want to look at the code just
send me an email I'll send it to you so
let's look at some experiments so we
encoded the Delaunay refinement problem
from the lonestar benchmarks in this
language and here the data set had about
100,000 triangles of them almost half of
them were initially bad and there were
12 8 threads so this is what the mesh
looked like after a lot of triangulation
so initially we started with a
partitioning of the mesh which was
fairly nice that it's this grid right
and then we note that even after many
thousands of rhe triangulations the mesh
that results still kind of looks like a
grid which means that there is a lot of
locality in these computations it's not
just that the structure completely
dissolves after all these
operations and and and so that is the
property we try to exploit so now as for
our numbers so we have a lot of
overheads actually because of the fact
that we are running on top of the Java
Virtual Machine and we are making
expensive method calls for pretty much
every single thing that we are when we
try to check whether if an assembly
contains a certain object or not we have
to make a method call and it turned out
that these method calls also eat up a
lot of time however I must say that this
is DST m2 which is more recently his
software transactional library and you
know we are only beating the sequential
version at eight course but we are our
overheads are still way better than them
in at least in this application and this
is perhaps a more accurate measure of
performance so this is a called this is
self relative speed up which is speed up
over the sequential version of the of
the same same system so this is an
attempt to rule out some of the effects
caused by these overheads so here if we
noted that we are pretty much close to
DST em but we are still perhaps a little
bit better but i would say that we are
pretty much this we pretty much have the
same curve SDS TM which is actually
interesting why these two things are
very similar so that's something to
observe a few relatively flat for some
cpus you investigate
yeah so we tried to investigate but we
did not have any answer so the problem
with this java based system is that
there is no underlying performance model
and i'm going to in fact show you a
graph in a little bit which is really
mind-boggling so we had absolutely no
clue why this happened but the
performance started to drop just when
you move from seven threads to eight
threads not in our model mind you when
you try to use fine-grained locking so
the performance suddenly collapsed when
you went from seven threads to eight
threads and we predict that this is
because of the garbage collector but we
have no clue what exactly is happening
there so what about the number of
conflicts so we define conflicts in DST
m2 in the usual way that how many
transactions are rolled back so we also
wrote a fine-grained locking
implementation as you saw in the
previous slides also so here a conflict
meant that you are trying to build a
cavity but then you have to basically
stop doing it and go back to the
original state so our fine-grained locks
are not blocking locks so basically you
try to a queue or a triangle and expand
your cavity and then if you cannot then
you just jump ship and then go back to
the original state and try to start
again and we found that the number of
conflicts in our system is actually very
very low which gives us hope that
perhaps if we have a more efficient
implementation we will be able to do get
better results yes please
so no we have not we do not have real
numbers for load balancing primarily
because the load balancing heuristic
that we gave be think that it's a very
simple thing and it can be improved
quite a bit and we would like to
investigate that more I understanding
for load balancing went admissions
officer walk trying to request yeah the
synchronize waiting I said you can when
working on one bigger assembly Brett are
just waiting either way correcting that
you can down
well it's more like that you are you you
are asked you are making a request from
a division which has lots of stuff to a
division which has very little stuff so
now just the normal migration would
bring stuff from the division which has
less to the division which has more but
that doesn't seem right so what we do is
that we exploit the property that these
migrations are symmetric and we
basically make the migration in the
other direction never never awesome
she'll be right back but not silence you
know so the problem the reason is that
these sizes are hard to track but one
would imagine that you could improve
this by having some sort of a heuristic
measure of the number of objects that
are there in the in the division
currently so as for both cars algorithms
so this was the bizarre graph that I was
telling you about which is that in this
fine grained locking implementation
perform and suddenly depth when we went
from seven threads to eight threads and
we looked at this code very very
carefully to see if there were any bugs
none that we could find so we suspect
that this is because of the of the
garbage collector but again we do not
really know why we were running with
eight course yes yet other hell's going
on yeah that's that's possible so the
interesting thing to note here is that
our selfie lative speed up on this
spanning tree application is actually
quite decent and the reason that the DST
em there is no graph corresponding to no
line corresponding to D STM is that we
couldn't run the STM on this application
because it's so big d STM just ran out
of memory immediately okay but here's
the sad part of this application which
is that our raw speed ups were rather
miserable even though our self ility
speed has quite good but again we are
hoping for a better implementation and
and maybe this can be improved but I'm
not claiming that this is fundamentally
because of implementation overheads it
may be that our approach is also has
some fundamental problems but we do not
know basically
whoa Ross Phillip is just you run the
sequential version of the code and your
you plot the the speed up over the
sequential version whereas in the self
relative speed up you plot the your
performance versus your performance on
one code or one fed so the basically the
sequential sequential version of your
system that's the baseline in this self
elit of speed up and the other one is
the is the best sequential
implementation which is just written in
in in just Java hello it is take it if I
find one yeah so that's yeah exactly
well so you will be surprised so
initially it was about 25 times and then
we found that if we replace these
exceptions by just simple checks like
where you did not have to prepare a
stack each time then immediately jump
from 25 times to 10 times so now our
understanding of the of the overheads is
not that deep it would be useful to talk
to somebody who knows the details of the
java runtime system but this is the best
that we could do at least for now okay
and in ongoing work I am working with
Professor Vivek soccer at Rice
University to embed this chorus model
into habanero Java which is an offshoot
of extent which Vivek spearheaded the
development of so here the point is that
that this this habanero Java already has
these abstractions for isolation however
these are coarse grained and static so
what we want to have is this more
fine-grained adaptive construct for
abstraction for isolation which is will
be as you saw here and then there are
some other things that are being
considered in this setting so in
particular in the model that I showed
you the objects where either completely
in the ownership of one assembly or or
not owned at all however we are
considering these abstractions for
fractional ownership where multiple
assemblies can earn an object however
aliasing is still very tightly control
and other ongoing work includes a more
optimized implementation so my student
is working hard at is hard at it right
as we speak and we are also looking at a
foundational process calculus for the
problems actually that's where we
started in in in in all of this so I am
primarily a theoretician and our initial
goal was to write to develop a
foundational calculus for local
computing in graphs but then it became a
more perhaps realistic thing but now we
still want to address this question that
what would buy calculus with merges and
splits and ownership transfer look like
and we are investigating that and
finally as somebody who's primarily
interested in program verification I am
interested in also questions about type
systems for chorus that what how do we
reason about type state of these
assemblies and how can you do some
static analysis so these are all
questions that we want to do and then
finally one other interesting
application of chorus seems to be in
these modular robotics where there is
there are these self-assembling robots
which are just running around in
parallel and they get together do some
stuff and then break off again and do
some other stuff so that seems to be
quite similar at least from a super at a
superficial level to our assemblies and
they're merging and splitting so we are
looking into those applications and
trying to see if we can program some of
them so for more information you can go
to this web page I don't think this web
page is up yet but it will be in a few
days and if you want the code once again
just ask me and the paper is published
in oopsla this year so if you want that
send email to and I'll end here then
take questions
you you say you're going back in to
start working on my type system and
static analysis yeah so so we are trying
to build this language and a more real
implementation of this language so we
already have an implementation which you
can download and use but we want to
integrate this with this habanero and
then there are these questions of what
are the types what do types mean for
this and what kind of compiler
optimizations can we do and all those
questions so so these are yes so I want
to address these questions it's almost
sounds like is almost a linear type type
setup yes yes sir but you know the
pitfalls are always fun right yes so
then maybe ask my question okay good
so
so this is if I wanted to use let's see
one user versed in eq paralyzed
so I would have to pay the notion of a
job right a job would correspond people
I guess triangles which are bad cavity
that even be triangulated ready and then
push them into a queue and have threads
like you know
steve jobs for the cute
right so the question is that what would
what kind of heuristics would you use to
maintain this job stealing so it cannot
be just completely naive right it cannot
be so so what you presumably do is that
you are going to perhaps use the same
kind of locality strategy that if you
are stealing a triangle then perhaps you
are going to also steal some local
triangles because that's that's because
you will use them afterwards right so in
some sense you can see our division
based runtime system as I an
implementation of what you said that
each division has a has a queue which
steals work from another division which
is basically about migrating these
assemblies from one division to another
division and and there is load balancing
but just as you are going to have load
balancing in silk but the point is that
all of those things are hidden from the
programmer because you want to also
guarantee this high level property is
like grace freedom and deadlock freedom
and so on just by your language street
yes that's actually a thought that I did
not have but yes that seems like a
possible ideas
I mean ok so I would be yeah I would be
hesitant to say yes completely and the
reason is that these questions like
deadlock freedom there you have to we
have to do some special things to do to
ensure that so I do not know if we just
do a knife translation into silk we will
get all those properties automatically
so that will require some thought sure
yes you all make sure there is no less
you on the sequel ownership oh because
there is there are no reference is being
transferred right the only way you you
do any kind of passing of objects from
one assembly to another is VR this March
right or or split so when you do a marg
you are just giving the entire region to
another assembly so you are not so nice
about your language level you are
passing all the way over loads and
stores and we see they're going through
a local part of the heap
yes that is right that's it yeah yeah so
that's where the find operation comes in
so this probably the major work on the
current of the heavy into the right we
need you to sit intercept and check it
goes right so not every is one of the
reason for foley use ten percent and
slow down right well I I agree that that
is a that is perhaps yeah so I agree
that that is perhaps the biggest
bottleneck but I think so 11
clarification though is that we do not
need to monitor every single rights so
really we can store some notion of a
boundary of these objects so you can do
some optimizations which will guarantee
that certain accesses are guaranteed to
be local but sometimes you are not sure
and then yes you will have to do this
sort of check this a member so one
difference though is that you are doing
this only at a completely local level
right so in case of the transactional
memory if you have at least an
implementation which is global your
conflict detection routine is going to
go through the going to have to go
through the entire memory whereas here
this sort of check that whether you are
going outside or whether you are staying
inside that's something that you are
doing using that find operation in
union-find right and it's also a local
thing that you know if this as you saw
in that mesh refinement example the NSM
an assembly contains what maybe ten
triangles so it's really about checking
these nine or ten edges that go out of
an assembly and and try to see if it
depends on the size of the absolutely so
this is yo Keem proposition
sure so but what I'm saying is that the
the property that we are trying to
exploit is that there is a lot of
parallelism at a low level at at a
fine-grained level and that's the
property we are trying to exploit so in
cases when there is no such parallelism
then yes it will just reduce to doing
these sorts of global just an organized
checks sure she knows that I know
essentially the same is just a virtual
number I mean you can have better more
efficient implementation megan is more
efficient up no no but that but the
basic point I want to make is that the
only difference between that sort of
checking that goes on in transactional
memory and here is just that we are
using this local property that we are
operating on local regions so if you
said that this was a this these
assemblies contain the entire heap so in
that case yes there is no difference at
all in terms of overheads actions cannot
see something outside its instructions
you need to monitor right but remember
that in transactions there is no
annotation of this is the region that
this transaction belongs to so so
transactions are are referred to
atomicity of control in some sense and
the and the data is really just one
global blob and you can just go whatever
do whatever you want to do the one you
even think they read in Rises itself
sure but if you have got if you have the
if you have heap allocated data
structures and if you have a field
expressions then you will have to
basically do some either some kind of
analysis some kind of shape analysis to
see how far you can go or you will have
to do it dynamically by doing a check so
here all we are exploiting is the
locality property that that that in
these applications the parallel
computations are restricted to these
local regions in the in the heap and
that's what we are exploiting here
yeah or something about the ease of
programming respect to find three
knocking more transactional
transactional memory is easy to program
in but find red locking is pretty
horrible even in these are these
applications which are not that
complicated just trying to make sure
that there are no dead locks and and no
aliases are going from here to there so
that's that's a huge pain so I think
that in terms of ease of programming as
you saw that application took only 10
lines of extra cold over the sequential
version so I think that it's it seems
very natural at least for these classes
of applications the way 10-19 Jamie's
why you only got ten percent of the
performance oh sure sure sure sure sure
yeah that's right no but there I would
point you to DST m/s understand this
video again